a blockbuster report claims the fbi
flagged all harassment of school
officials kindergartners learned about
transgenderism and the written house
jury continues its liberation i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with the
vpn i trust visit expressvpn.com
slash ben will get to all the news in
just one moment first you know black
friday is coming and that's when the
savings begin but here's the thing you
could be saving a lot of money right now
by not paying your cell phone provider a
lot of money for the same exact coverage
you could be getting with pure talk you
could be cutting your cell phone bill in
half if you just switch over to pure
talk pure talk will give you killer 5g
coverage on one of the largest 5g
networks in the country and still save
the average family over 800 a year i
made the switch the coverage is
excellent their us-based customer
service actually cares about you and
pure tax prices are pretty much
wholesale we've got unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data for just 30 a month
i've got other options as well keep your
number keep your phone or this month get
black friday prices on new phones but
you can get the iphone 12 for just 479
which is like a massive deal they've got
a 30-day risk-free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose head on
over to puretalk.com shop for the plan
and phone that is right for you then
enter promo code shapiro you will save
50 off your very first month and save on
a new phone as well that is puretalk.com
promo code shapiro puretalk is simply
smarter wireless some restrictions apply
see site for details cut that phone bill
in half switch on over to puretalk at
puretalk.com and use promo code shapiro
to save 50 off your very first month and
save on a new phone all righty so
the cal written house jury continues its
deliberations in the meantime the media
continue their
absolutely hot takes on the written
house trial remember this is just a pack
of lies on top of the pack of lies the
media have told so many lies at this
point about rittenhouse that makes your
head swim
remember this whole thing began with the
lie that america's police are
systemically racist because of derrick
chovin and george floyd despite the fact
that there was never any actual racial
evidence shown in the trial of derek
chovin then the media lied about jacob
blake they suggested that he was an
innocent black man who was shot down by
a bunch of racist white cops when in
fact it turns out that jacob blake was
out on an an actual warrant for third
degree sexual assault and he was called
to the scene of a of a potential crime
by the girl who had alleged the sexual
assault against him the police arrived
he refused to drop his knife he resisted
arrest and they shot him and the media
lied and they said the police were
racist and this was just another
indicator that america was systemically
racist then riots broke out in kenosha
wisconsin which is where jacob blake was
shot
and you'll remember that the media
declared that the riots were actually
mostly peaceful protests there's the
famous picture of the guy standing in
front of a burning building going it's
fiery but mostly peaceful from cnn
so that was another lie and then you had
the lie that kyle rittenhouse must have
shown up in order to do damage that
night rather than in order to help and
then there was the lie that he shot
everybody because he was an active
shooter and he was being chased down by
a mob of do-gooders
okay so all of those lies added up to a
media narrative that was completely at
odds with all physical reality in every
single one of those cases and they're
not going to let go now
so the view which is just a a repository
of the heights of human stupidity
had has a bunch of people who are just
awful at their jobs one of those people
is whoopi goldberg and
she says that if the jury in the written
house trial acquits kyle rittenhouse the
charges of murder despite the fact that
he obviously acted in self-defense if
they acquit him
then this would be a message that it is
okay to shoot both black people and
white people which is an interesting
take considering that
it was never okay to shoot black people
who are innocent and also not okay to
shoot white people who aren't innocent
and um anyway here's whoopi goldberg
so i mean how do you see this ending i
think it's really
uh a red light for for
white folks coming to help
uh
at social justice
uh protests because basically what
they're saying is oh it's okay to shoot
white people too
what no
it's okay to shoot white people so so
somehow this has been turned by the left
media people like whoopi goldberg into a
referendum on whether white people ought
to help people at black lives matter
protest because they might get shot too
because they are black adjacent or
something okay but it wasn't just whoopi
goldberg on the view tara setmeyer i
mean they had themselves a day on the
view
the view as i've said before one of my
goals in life is to be invited on the
view because it would just be absolute
carnage which is exactly why they will
never invite me on the view i know this
because i've spoken to people who
have been on the view and are on the
view and produced for the view and uh
let's just say that they are never going
to allow somebody like me on the view
it'd be a massive mistake on their part
and they know in any case tara setmeyer
is also on the view and she suggested
that kyle written house is a murderer
based on no available evidence
it's difficult for people who are
responsible gun owners this guy is not a
martyr he is not a martyr he's a
murderer and this should not be you
should not be
empowered
by technicalities like this
okay so um yeah this is the media's hot
take and of course it has nothing to do
with reality but the narrative always
takes precedence always and how many
cases have the media gotten wrong over
the past 10 years have they ever gotten
a case wrong in the direction of the
right ever
or what why is it that every time they
screw something up it benefits the
narrative of the left strange how that
works almost as though they are a
propaganda wing of the democratic party
meanwhile in what is not a national news
story apparently the kyle written house
judge has now received hundreds of bile
messages
wishing most heinous homicide on his
kids and threatening his own life
is according to the daily mail as
reported by the daily wire judge bruce
schroeder who's overseeing the homicide
trial of teenager kyle rittenhouse has
received hundreds of vile messages from
detractors according to a daily mail
report outlined last week correspondence
reportedly sent to the kenosha county
courthouse and reviewed by the daily
mail revealed threats against trader's
life as well as on his children
a facts the courthouse received in
october reads this is outrageous what
fresh hell is this written house is a
murderous thug and trying to protect him
says a lot about this judge
presumably the email came in reaction to
the judge ruling in a pre-trial hearing
for the case that prosecutors are barred
from referring to the men shot by
rittenhouse as victims
we are watching the message continues
enjoy your term judge it's going to be
your last if i ever meet you in person i
fully intend to spit directly into your
face regardless of the cost you're
disgusting another chilling message
wishes quote the most heinous homicide
known to man on schrader's children one
day hope his kids become victims to the
most heinous homicide known to man so he
feels the pain and we will not call his
kids victims it reads
well way to name white skin head hothead
to be a judge another message says no
wonder they burn down your city so good
times now
if this judge had been favorable toward
the prosecution and it had been a bunch
of right-wingers sending these messages
to the judge you think it might be a
national news story that the judge was
receiving bevis of death threats i think
it probably would but again the
narrative matters more than anything
else okay in just one second i want to
get to what i think is the continuing
biggest story in the country after
loudoun county virginia and it is the
story that parents should keep their eye
on as a parent it is the story that
concerns me the most in america we'll
get to that in just one moment first
let's talk about a great christmas gift
i'm talking about my pillow my pillow
wants to give back to our listeners you
can get great discounts on all my pillow
products today if you go to mypillow.com
right now and click on the radial
listener specials get deep discounts on
my pillows mattress toppers towels and
so much more for example my pillow is
offering a buy one get one free offer on
giza sheets these are top quality sheets
that you will love
all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listener specials for
the buy one get one free offer on the
giza sheets use promo code daily wire at
checkout or call 1-800-651-1148
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including pillow
slippers the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets all this stuff
is just top-notch product is going to
enrich your life it's going to make you
feel a lot wealthier than you are no
matter how wealthy are because that's
just how good this stuff is that's
mypillow.com enter code dailywire or
call
1-800-651-1148 tell them the daily wire
sent you that is 1-800-651-1111
makes a fantastic holiday gift these
deals won't last forever call right now
mypillow.com enter code dailywire or
call 1-800-651-1148
and tell them that we here at the daily
wire sent you alrighty so
the biggest story in the country right
before the virginia gubernatorial
election was the battle between parents
and school boards and you'll recall
that the doj
basically acceded to a request from the
national school boards union the
national school boards association to
start looking into
people who are upset with school boards
as potential domestic terrorists there's
a letter sent from the nsba to the fbi
and the doj asking them to treat people
who are criticizing school boards
overtly and voraciously to treat to
treat them as though they were domestic
terrorists they tried to invoke the
patriot act and you'll remember that
merrick garland was brought before a
senate committee and he was asked about
surveilling parents and checking into
parents and was the doj going after
parents for the great crime of being
angry at their school boards and here's
what merrick garland had to say
what does the national security division
have to do with parents at school boards
this is not again about parents at
school boards it's about threats of
violence section 223
that statute covers
the use of not just telephones but
telecommunications devices
to annoy to annoy someone
so are you gonna sick your u.s attorneys
in the fbi on a parent's group if they
post on facebook something that annoys a
school board member judge answer that is
no
so they're not going to do that right
they're definitely not going to track
people's communications they're not
going to spend their time doing this
okay so now according to the wall street
journal breaking story fbi tracks
threats against teachers school board
members
quote the federal bureau of
investigation has set up a process to
track threats against school board
members and teachers moving to implement
a justice department directed that some
law enforcement officials and republican
lawmakers say could improperly target
parents protesting local education
policies the heads of the fbi criminal
encounter terrorism divisions instructed
agents in an october 20th memo to flag
all assessments and investigations into
potential potentially criminal threats
and harassment and intimidation of
educators with a threat tag which
officials said would allow them to
evaluate the scope of the problem
the internal email asks fbi agents to
consider the motivation behind any
criminal threat and whether it
potentially violates federal law
agents should tag such threats edge
officials you better track them
according to the memo which was reviewed
by the wall street journal
okay and the story continues the purpose
of the threat tag is to help scope this
threat on a national level and provide
an opportunity for comprehensive
analysis of the threat picture for
effective engagement with law
enforcement partners at all levels says
the email signed by the fbi's assistant
director for counterterrorism
an fbi agent provided a copy of the
internal email to several republican
lawmakers citing concerns that could
open the door for the bureau to collect
information on parents voicing their
opposition to local school policies
during meetings
the fbi said tuesday in a statement the
fbi has never been in the business of
investigating parents who speak out or
policing speech at school board meetings
and we are not going to start now we are
fully committed to preserving and
protecting first amendment rights
including freedom of speech the new
procedures were prompted by an october
4th memo from a.g merrick garland
ordering the fbi to help local leaders
address threats to school personnel a
move he has said was aimed at stopping
violence against teachers and school
staff over politically charged issues
now the question of course is why that's
not a local law enforcement issue if
somebody issues a threat against me i
report it to local law enforcement that
we get threats all the time they report
it to local law enforcement
it is not an fbi issue why is the fbi
investigating this the reason the fbi is
doing it is at the behest of the nsba
the fbi in its statement described a
threat tag as a tool to compile
statistics and track information about a
range of issues
the creation of a threat tag in no way
changes the long-standing requirements
for opening an investigation nor does it
represent a shift in how the fbi
prioritizes threats said the statement
garland said during a correct
congressional hearing last month that
while he didn't have a full accounting
of such threats nationwide complaints
from school board officials and news
reports show that the problem is
becoming more prevalent now again the
question becomes he was asked
specifically do you know of a serious
uptick in death threats and he said no i
really don't have evidence of that we
just have kind of news reports
why this merits a federal investigation
and a publicly stated federal
investigation is sort of beyond me
the other problem of course is that your
trust in the fbi has been somewhat
shaken over the past few years given the
fact that the fbi initiated an entire
investigation against carter page based
on the clinton campaign just making up
crap about donald trump and then handing
it over to the fbi and that eventually
would be mainstreamed into the steele
dossier which would be mainstreamed into
the media which would be mainlined into
the mueller report
so yeah my trust in institutional law
enforcement to look into quote-unquote
threats by parents
i am i'm skeptical to say the least
some republicans say the justice
department is thrusting the fbi into
what is usually considered a local issue
they say the tactics are an effort to
silence parents who speak out at school
board meetings about topics such as mass
mandates and how race is addressed in
schools
the ag issued his directive shortly
after the nsba asked president biden in
a letter for federal help in dealing
with threats by people opposed to face
mask mandates for stemming covenant 19
and to the teaching of critical race
theory the association has since
apologized for the letter which
suggested that the doj treat attacks and
threats against public school officials
as hate crimes or domestic terrorism
a spokesman for the group didn't
immediately respond to requests for
comment on tuesday
at a house intelligence subcommittee
hearing earlier this month several
republican lawmakers pressed
the fbi on the new directive does the
fbi consider parents domestic terrorists
at representative elise stefanik of new
york switch the fbi representative said
no quoting as long as individuals are
not committing federal violations force
or violence and promoting an ideology
they would not be
okay but that october 20th email
suggests a broad-based
concern by the fbi with parental
feedback aimed at school boards
according to
javed ali who teaches the university of
michigan the fbi will have to tread very
carefully they can't open investigations
into people showing up and protesting
when someone crosses the line of direct
threats of violence whether in the
physical domain or virtually that is
crime but the question is why is the fbi
involved in this at all and why are they
publicly announcing that they are
involved in this other than to attempt
to quash people suggesting
criticism of public school officials
and here's the thing
you're public school officials
and and it seems to be true across a
wide variety of states public school
officials are very often directly at
odds with parents
they're they are enabling and
effectuating policy that is rooted in
radical ideas about gender about race in
the united states and parents have every
right to be pissed off every parents
have every right to radically
transparent to oversight of these school
boards when you delegate your kids to
the public schools you are not saying
that the public schools get to educate
your kid in whatever the public schools
you fit you are saying that your
educational priorities ought to be put
into what the schools teach your kids
hey that you're delegating okay you
you're reserving the right to educate
your kids
but you are delegating that right to the
schools with the understanding that they
are then not going to indoctrinate your
children and a bunch of radical garbage
and yet that is precisely what our
public schools are doing across the
nation i'll get to some of those stories
in a second because this scares the
living hell out of me and it should
scare the living hell out of you
okay because the public schools are
still churning out the majority of
students in this country
they're affecting how families operate
they're affecting how families are able
to teach their values to their children
it's why we need school vouchers across
this country as fast as humanly possible
every parent not just the wealthy should
have the ability to take their kids out
of the local public school and put their
kid into a school that reflects their
values
it is imperative at this point
and there has to be a radical shift in
how these school boards operate and if
the school boards don't want people
taking money out of the public schools
and putting their kids in private
schools maybe they ought to start
reflecting the priorities of the
parental communities that they actually
are supposed to serve we'll get to this
in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact if you're looking
for ways to skip the trip to the post
office and dodge all that hectic holiday
shopping traffic you could save time and
money with stamps.com stamps.com lets
you compare rates print labels access
exclusive discounts on ups or usps
services all year long it makes a lot of
sense especially if your business sends
more mail in packages during the
holidays here at daily wire we've used
stamps.com since 2017 no more wasting
our time whether you're selling online
or running an office or side hustle
stamps.com can save you so much time
money and stress during the holidays
access all the post office and ups
shipping services you need without
taking the trip and get discounts you
can't find anywhere else like up to 40
off usps rates and 76 percent off ups
going to the post office instead of
using stamps.com is kind of like taking
the stairs instead of the elevator just
going up a couple of floors sure take
the stairs but if you're walking 30
flights a day you really should be using
the elevator okay that means using
stamps.com we use stamps.com here at
daily wire we've been using it for years
we are not going to waste our time and
money save time and money this holiday
season with stamps.com sign up with
promo coach shapiro for a special offer
that includes a four week trial free
postage digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the page enter code shapiro to
get started okay so here are some of the
stories that are creating alarm among
parents and they should be creating
alarm among parents and they are from
all over the country
so this one from brittany bernstein over
at national review reporting on the
situation in west hartford connecticut
quote elementary school students in west
hartford connecticut public schools are
being forced to undergo social emotional
learning through an equity lens as
district officials have reportedly told
parents they may not opt out of the
curriculum which aims to teach students
a set of social justice standards
parents from the district district
contacted the non-profit parents
defending education to share concerns
over material being used to teach
elementary students about group
identities including transgender content
being taught to kindergarten students
one parent raised a red flag about when
aidan became a brother a book being
taught to fourth grade students that the
parent described as full-on gender
theory which is teaching students that
the sex you're assigned at birth is
wrong
the description of the book reads when
aiden was born everyone thought he was a
girl his parents gave him a pretty name
his room looked like a girl's room he
wore clothes that other girls liked
wearing after he realized he was a trans
boy aiden and his family
fixed the parts of his life that didn't
fit anymore and he settled happily into
his new life
when aiden's parents announced they're
having a second child aiden wants to do
everything he can to make things right
for his new sibling from the beginning
including choosing the best name and
picking out the right decor and clothes
the book asks what making things right
actually means
another fourth grade mentor text is a
book about pronouns called they she he
me free to be
the lessons are supposed to teach
students in kindergarten about social
justice standards including identity
diversity justice and action
the identity standard includes texts
that teach students about transgender
people and the use of preferred pronouns
including the inclusive singular they
a mentor text for a kindergartner
student is introducing teddy which tells
a story about a character and his teddy
thomas thomas says i've always known
that i'm a girl teddy not a boy teddy i
wish my name was tilly not thomas
another text for the kindergarten age
group is let's talk about race
meanwhile a first grade text includes
jacob's new dress a story about a girl a
story about a boy who wants to wear a
dress to school and are you a boy or are
you a girl a book about a character who
prefers not to tell other children
whether they are a boy or a girl
third graders are reading a similar book
called ten thousand dresses about a book
about a boy named bailey who dreams of
magical dresses but people in his life
tell him he should not be thinking about
dresses because he's a boy but later he
begins making dresses with a new friend
fifth graders read i am jazz and it
feels good to be yourself which says
quote some people are boys some people
are girls some people are both neither
or somewhere in between
in an emailed appearance the district's
director of equity advancement dr regina
haskins explains that the schools have
quote redoubled district-wide efforts to
attend to the social and emotional needs
of children and adults
it explains that the aforementioned
social justice standards come from the
framework of the collaborative for
academic social and emotional learning
haskins writes that the group
acknowledges that while sel alone will
not solve long-standing and deep-seated
inequities in the education system it
can help schools promote understanding
examined biases reflect on and address
the impact of racism close opportunity
gaps and create a more inclusive school
community so we are now indoctrinating
kindergartners
in connecticut in the idea that boys and
girls are malleable categories and that
a boy can be a girl and a girl can be a
boy because there is nothing that is
healthier for a child than confusing
them about their gender let me just
explain something about children i have
three there are seven five and one if
anybody approached my kids and started
telling them about how they might be a
member of the opposite sex
that person would be out of my house so
fast would make your head swim this is
predatory behavior upon children
confusing children about their sex is
disgusting it's disgusting gender
dysphoria is an actual condition
it is not a cute little thing that ought
to be promulgated to
tens of millions of school children
across the united states gender
dysphoria is an actual mental disorder
according to the dsm-5
pretending that mental disorder is
is a
somehow referendum on the notion that
there are binary sexes in life
or that your child should be taught
about the supposed malleability of sex
contra all science and evidence is a way
for you to prey on children it's a way
for you to screw up kids who are not
suffering from gender dysphoria
the belief that in service to kids who
have gender dysphoria you have to screw
up an entire generation of children by
telling them
that inborn biological characteristics
are of no consequence whatsoever
is it's vile and parents should be
standing up to it at every single level
and it's not just in connecticut
in one second i'll tell you some more
stories about what's happening at
schools across the nation first let's
talk about a simple fact
there are a lot of crimes out there that
you already know about right burglary
you got
fire you got people who are breaking
into your house right all this stuff
thank god you can get insurance for
where you can you can protect against
there is one sort of of crime that your
home owner's policy really doesn't cover
it's called home title fraud the fbi
calls title fraud one of the fastest
growing crimes it can ruin you
financially which is why you need home
title lock title fraud happens when a
criminal forges your signature on
documents stating you sold your home to
him then he takes out loans against your
home and leaves you with the payment
you'll spend a fortune in legal fees
trying to prove you didn't commit fraud
home title lock puts a barrier around
your home's title the instant they
detect anyone from a cyber thief to a
renter to a relative
trying to forge their way onto your
home's title they help shut it down go
to hometitlelock.com register your
address to see if you're already a
victim and enter code radio for 30 days
of free protection that is code radio
home title lock dot com again that is
home title lock dot com use code radio
for 30 days of free protection home
title lock.com use code radio that will
remind them that we sent you in the
first place okay so it is not merely
connecticut public schools that are now
teaching this sort of crap according to
the new york post a new hampshire
teenager is suing his school district
after he was allegedly suspended from
athletics for saying there are only two
genders
the exeter high school freshman said in
the suit he was hit with a one game
football suspension in september
stemming from a text conversation he had
with another student off school grounds
the lawsuit was filed november 4th
through an attorney with the christian
organization cornerstone action with the
claim that he stated a catholic-based
belief that there are only male and
female genders
by the way that's not a catholic-based
belief that's reality
okay because either gender is a complete
spectrum in which there are an infinite
number of genders or there is a male
gender and a female gender and you can
sometimes have characteristics of one or
the other while being a biological male
so you can be an effeminate male or you
can be a very masculine female but that
does not change the fact that male and
female are categories that exist
the kids lawsuit also claims exeter's
policy on non-binary gender identity and
pronouns infringes on his first
amendment rights the policy says
students have a right to be addressed a
right to be addressed by a name and
pronoun of their choosing related to
their gender identities and also says
those who don't recognize other's gender
identities or pronouns are violating the
policy
the student
was suspended for denying that people
can belong to a gender other than that
of male or female
the student it goes on will never refer
to any individual person using plural
pronouns such as they using contrived
pronouns such as g or with any similar
terminology that reflects values the
student does not share
the suspension came after the student
had been engaged in a conversation on
the bus over gender with friends over
the perceived difficulty in using plural
pronouns for an individual in spanish
which uses masculine and feminine
plurals a female student overheard the
discussion allegedly told the student
there were more than two genders no
there aren't there's only two genders
the student allegedly replied
that conversation continued in
contentious text exchange which was
shown to him by school administrators in
printed form when he was suspended
so students now being suspended for the
great crime of pointing out the reality
which is that male and female are
categories that exist
meanwhile in florida according to
breitbart.com parents of a 13 year old
daughter have filed a federal lawsuit
against a florida school district after
officials at deer lake middle school
secretly transitioned her into a
transgender male or a biological girl
who says she wants to live as a boy
including her
including allowing her to use male
spaces like bathrooms and choosing
pronouns
and this of course is the scariest and
most insane thing that is happening at
our nation's public schools not just
happening in the public schools by the
way
it's happening in the medical context as
well abigail schreier reported on this
case in washington state where there was
a kid who was suicidal happened to be
autistic was put on 72-hour suicide
watch and in the process of that suicide
watch
the administrators at this facility
convinced the kid basically that he was
a member of the opposite gender and then
told the parents that unless they
started transition processes
the kid would not be released back to
them the parents took the kid moved out
of state the kid is still living as his
biological sex happily not in the state
of washington okay now we're seeing this
happen in public schools
jeffrey and january little john's
daughter who is referred to as a.g in
court filings did talk about her gender
confusion with her mother who holds a
master's degree in counseling from
florida state university
january spoke at a gathering of the
florida family policy council about the
school withholding from her and her
husband what the school did without
their knowledge or permission
she said when our daughter told us she
was experienced to stress about her
gender at the height of the pandemic we
were completely caught by surprise she'd
expressed no signs of gender confusion
or distress in early childhood or
leading up to this announcement so we
were trying our best to navigate these
uncharted waters and support her in the
best way we could and help her through
her feelings we found a counselor
started our own research which led us to
gender ideology
apparently according to a lawsuit filed
by the parents this is the washington
examiner now the lawsuit says the little
johns informed their daughter's math
teacher rima kelly about their
teenager's gender dysphoria and
continued treatment with the mental
health counselor kelly offered to inform
the school about their daughter's desire
to identify as non-binary the parents
declined a couple of weeks later while
she was getting into the car the little
john's daughter mentioned the school had
asked her which bathroom she wanted to
use which the lawsuit says she thought
was funny
january littlejohn told the washington
examiner that was the first time she
became aware that the school was meeting
with her daughter assisting the teenager
in embracing a different gender identity
in school settings
the school claimed the child needed to
authorize her
needed to needed to authorize for her
parents to be at the meeting
so in other words according to the
school if the kid didn't authorize the
parents the parents could not be at the
meeting so just to get this straight in
public schools you cannot give a
band-aid or an advil to a child without
parental permission but if the kid comes
in and says i'm a member of the opposite
gender the parents are not allowed to
know about it according to many of these
schools unless the kid gives permission
the little john's attorney bernadette
broyles of a nonprofit law firm called
the child and parental rights campaign
said the school could not provide the
text the law officials referred to the
examiner reported the lawsuit says the
school district was relying upon lcs
lesbian gay bisexual transgender gender
non-conforming and questioning support
guide which expressly directs school
administrators to avoid notifying the
child's parents about a child's gender
identity claiming such an action could
lead to the student becoming homeless in
other words the school cares more about
the kid than the parents do which is the
big lie that you're constantly told by
left-wing school public school officials
we care more about your kids than you do
yes screw you you don't you don't
i guarantee you parents care more about
their kids
on average
than school administrators do
and the belief that school
administrators have any level of
expertise navigating gender dysphoria is
insane
it's also insane
that all of these
public interest groups on behalf of
radical gender ideology are the ones
writing the guides for the schools
that's totally crazy
so you have a left-wing organization
like glad writing the the policy
prescriptions for how to treat
kids who are gender confused at the age
of eight
insane
and non-reflective of what parents
actually want
and it's not just on issues of gender
ideology radical gender ideology
it's also with regard to critical race
theory which continues to be taught in
schools despite the fact that the left
continues to lie about it
so eric schmidt
who is a candidate for the u.s senate in
missouri
he has filed a lawsuit against the
springfield public school teachers
because they've been teaching
critically they've been forcing the
teachers to to learn critical race
theory at the springfield public schools
so you can see some of their some of the
slides that they're being forced to
learn
they were forced to learn about the
quote-unquote oppression matrix this is
the teachers
that shows different types of oppression
whether you're a privileged social group
what oppressed social groups look like
so racism white people are the
privileged social group asian black
latino and native people are the
oppressed social groups unless of course
you're an asian student trying to get
into college at which point you become
part of the privileged social group
sexism is male assigned at birth
female assigned at birth is the
oppressed social group
it gets awkward though because if you're
a female who is assigned to birth and
you identify as male
then i guess that you could
theoretically be a sexist against
females but also you could be subjected
to transgender oppression
there's heterosexism
in which heterosexuals are the
privileged social group and lesbians and
gay men are the oppressed social group
there's classism in which rich people
are the privileged social group and poor
people are the oppressed social groups
this is what teachers are being taught
that all of america breaks down into a
variety of oppressed and oppressors
at other additional trainings
springfield public school teachers were
presented with images that classify
education funding from property tax as
covert white supremacy among other
examples
it is covert white supremacy according
to what these teachers are being taught
to believe in color blindness that is
covert white supremacy
white silence is covert white supremacy
so if you just disagree with an agenda
and don't say anything about it that is
covert white supremacy
if you call the police on a black person
that is covert white supremacy
unstated is the question of whether the
black person was committing a crime when
you call the police on them they have a
pyramid on understanding white supremacy
that they're those being taught to
springfield public school teachers
and so here's the thing
the the left has taken two tactics one
at first they claim that none of this
exists and it's all in your head which
is obviously untrue but the real tactic
in the end is going to be just overtly
defending this stuff and this is a
battle that republicans should want this
sabbatical this is a battle that
republicans should should desperately
crave
according to business insider quote
democrats plan to swing back
aggressively at republicans on critical
race theory claims
they've called it a racist dog whistle
and a lie but those messages haven't
helped democrats tamp down the uproar
republicans are fueling over critical
race theory now a misused catch-all term
for teaching on race and diversity in
k-12 schools firing up protests at
school board meetings around the country
democratic strategists say the party
should hit back harder against divisive
gop claims while not losing sight of the
priority for voters the economy jim
manley long time age former senate
minority leader harry reid says on a
political level it's a real threat that
is allowing republicans to claw back the
inroads democrats have made in the
suburbs over the last couple of election
cycles democrats haven't yet pushed back
on this issue enough but the good news
is the party's response is effective
there's time to make the case before the
2022 election said jesse ferguson a
democratic strategist they just need to
make the case relentlessly he said
votes run from the republicans when
democrats peel back the onion on what
these claims really mean he said it's
not just that republicans want a bigger
role for parents in education it's that
republicans are willing to let white
supremacists write the curricula
oh boy do this man seriously democrats
please embrace this message please
embrace the message that if i don't want
my kid indoctrinated in radical gender
garbage and if i don't want my kid
indoctrinated in nicole hannah jones
brand of bull crap then this means i'm
white supremacist please embrace this
please i beg you make this the
centerpiece of your campaign go to war
with parents do it
i mean they they will the media the
media are so in love with their own
masturbatory vision of what utopian
education looks like that's why nicole
hannah jones who is just a prevaricator
she's just a damned liar
and an ignoramus by the way i mean she's
fully
she says fully stupid crap on a regular
basis
last week she claimed that america
dropped the a-bomb on japan at the end
of world war ii in order to prove to the
world that they had spent the money on
the a-bomb wisely
that america basically dropped the bomb
on hiroshima and nagasaki because of the
sunk cost fallacy that's what an idiot
this human being is and she is trotted
out as some sort of massive intellectual
worthy of having her curriculum taught
your kids here she was on the view
pushing back against the crt backlash
well i think we can look at the backlash
to the 6019 project uh the the backlash
to the propaganda campaign against
critical race theory and see that we are
a country that has willfully
willfully um denied this history that is
not wanted to teach it and own up to the
fact that slavery is one of the oldest
institutions in america and so much of
the wealth of our country was built on
enslavement so much of our political
legal cultural systems but we have been
in denial about that and that's why you
see such a strong reaction to this work
no the reason that we see a strong
reaction to your work is because you're
a liar because you claimed that all of
america's central institutions were
founded upon slavery and that is a lie
you claimed that 1776 was fought in
order to preserve slavery that is a lie
it is not true
okay but
push back please do it do it according
to business insider the democratic
congressional campaign committee the
house campaign armed for democrats
downplayed the threats of the party in
congressional races this fall they
tested responses to false claims about
critical race theory in k-12 schools the
messages they say resonate with most
battleground voters democrats want to
teach the truth about u.s history and
honor those who fought to make the
country better republicans are trying to
divide americans democrats want to
deliver for american families
please i please i beg you to embrace
this i beg of you to please embrace
critical race theory and radical gender
ideology in the schools and they are
they are according to the washington
post opinion piece by katrina vanden
heuvel one of their columnists
she was the editor and publisher of the
nation magazine quote progressives can
no longer cede school boards to the gop
they should treat them as political
arenas to fight and win
today the right is turning its attention
to school boards and the consequences
for progressives and students across the
country could be dire while most school
board races are officially nonpartisan
most candidates nevertheless identify
with a particular political ideology and
securing wins down ballot can improve a
movement prospect up ballot by
mobilizing conservative candidates to
run for school elections and encouraging
their base to disrupt public meetings
republicans are building a strong
organizational structure to help them
fight culture wars on the ground and
seize power from the bottom up
progressives can no longer cede school
boards to the gop they would be wise to
treat those boards as political arenas
to fight and win
okay so she is she's claiming that
progressives should fight this fight
this month's gubernatorial election in
virginia demonstrated the culture wars
being fought in local school boards can
turn out voters and earn their support
conservatives are planning to use the
glenn young can playbook in 2022 but
progressives have a playbook to follow
as well
as my nation colleague john nichols
pointed out on the same night junking
one voters in one wisconsin school
district successfully stopped one of the
aforementioned right-wing recall efforts
progressive parents organized and
communicated effectively about the value
of a curriculum that embraces diversity
and teaches students critical thinking
in other words a local community
mobilized to face conservative
misinformation about crt head-on and one
on the merits please do this seriously
because going to war with parents
that's a losing proposition for
democrats but parents have to get
mobilized they have to get motivated
they have to get mobilized so here's
what i want seriously i'm going to ask
of you today if you are a parent in a
school district kids are going to public
school or private school and they're
being indoctrinated with this sort of
garbage please send whatever information
you have to us here at daily wire my
personal email address is b shapiro
dailywire.com i want you to send me that
information so we can put our
investigative team on it
i want radical transparency for our
public schools and yes private schools
that are indoctrinating students in ways
that are absurd
i want parents broadly rich to know what
their kids are learning
what the state and localities are
teaching your kids in school so if you
have that information check your kids
syllabi check what the teachers are
teaching your kids and if you're
spotting that your kids are being
indoctrinated with radical gender
ideology
that requires public explication it
requires public reporting we have an
investigative team here at daily wire
we've worked hard and spent a lot of
money building it please send me
personally your tips i am happy to pass
that on to our investigative team it's
the most important issue in the country
the raising of the next generation and
the values that we inculcate in that
generation matter
and contra a lot of folks on the right
who will say that schools are just
supposed to teach you
how to think not what to think what to
think is very often a component of how
to think the left knows this they want
you to think through a certain a certain
framework about gender about identity
about politics
pushing back against that is an act of
good get involved today become
you gotta as my mentor andrew breitbart
once said if you got a cell phone you're
not a reporter
well if you're a parent you got a kid in
school it is up to you to make sure that
the rest of the country knows what's
going on in your school district so
again my email address be shapiro
dailywire.com for any tips on this
particular subject i think it's the most
important subject in the country
okay in just one second we'll get to the
continuing quest by the left to erase
people who counter their prevailing
narratives first let's talk about a
simple fact the gas prices are up once
more i mean they're like six dollars a
gallon in certain places in california
you need to be saving on gas it's that
simple thanks to joe biden let's go
brandon well here's the thing you need
get upside my listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download that
free get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
shapiro get a bonus 25 cents per gallon
on your first fill up
that is up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free use promo code shapiro
to get up to 50 cents per gallon cash
back on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back there is no cash
the cash back gets added directly to
your account you can cash out any time
to your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands just
download that free get upside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your very first
tank of gas that is code shapiro go
check out the get upside app right now
use that promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank of gas and 25 cents per gallon on
every gallon after that alrighty austria
has now announced and is now enforcing a
lockdown for unvaxed citizens could the
same happen here if the federal
government got its way it very well
could sign our petition against joe
biden's vaccine mandate over at
dailywire.com
do not comply please help us send a
message to the biden administration
americans are not just going to do
whatever they are told you do the more
people sign the petition the louder the
message that's why we are aiming to get
to 1 million signatures we have well
over half a million already head on over
to dailywire.com
do not comply to sign that petition
today you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
here's the thing the culture that is
created by the radicals in the schools
well it bleeds up to every aspect of our
culture this is kind of an amazing story
and it is indicative of just where we
stand as a culture right now according
to the hollywood reporter harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone stars and
filmmaker chris columbus are reuniting
for a previously announced 20th
anniversary retrospective on hbo max
there's one notable omission from the
list of participants the person who
created all of harry potter jk rowling
why of course well we know the answer
why jk rowling says that men exist in
women exist she has as they say a turf a
trans-exclusionary radical feminist when
it became
a radical feminist ideal to point out
that women exist is beyond me it's
insane so
according to the left you are now a
radical feminist crazy if you oppose
pornography and believe women exist
so welcome to the traditional
conservative side of the aisle jk
rowling
harry potter's 20th anniversary return
to hogwarts will stream january 1st on
hbo max with a linear debut on tbs and
cartoon network in the spring
the failure to uh to name it rallying is
interesting rallying sparked backlash
according to the hollywood reporter from
the trans community after saying that
transgender individuals should be
defined by their biological sex well
actually no what she said is that their
biological sex is the only way that you
can label people by sex proclaiming that
a male as a female is idiotic which is
true sources close to the project note
the retrospective will focus on the
creation of the film and the central
cast and team rallying will be featured
in archival footage she just won't make
a new appearance still use the old
footage of jk rowling but we have to
pretend that she died years ago before
she started with this whole women exist
thing
it's incredible we're now erasing some
of the most prominent people in our
culture over the fact that they believe
that women exist
that is where we are right now and this
is part of a broader sensorious push by
the left to just get rid of anyone who
disagrees with them
it's the reason why you see the left
pushing on facebook and pushing on
youtube and pushing on twitter to bar
people who disagree with them
shutting off the the access to the
public is the only way of allowing
radicals to win because if these battles
are fought in the public sphere the left
loses the radical left will lose most
americans most people on earth do not
believe that men can become women most
people in the west do not believe you
should be primarily identified as an
oppressor or a member of depressed class
based on immutable characteristic
most people don't believe that and so
that leaves the radical left with one
choice try to shut down everybody who
disagrees and they're becoming more and
more overt about this it's not like
they're hiding the ball anymore right
whether it is trying to get professors
fired for mouthing platitudes like merit
ought to matter more than race or
whether you're talking about nicole
wallace on msnbc suggesting that fox
news is like a terror group i i gotta
tell you it is incredible to watch the
left just unmask in real time
i don't know how you can talk about
conspiracy theorists without talking
about
i think they've done more damage to the
party than anything i'm sure you do but
if we want to go through that i think
there are liars and conspiracy theorists
on msnbc and on cnn also so maybe i'll
write a book about all that but that's
not what this book is about in that
section of the book i'm talking to
republicans about the way i believe we
need to deal with media to be most
effective for winning
the conspiracy theorists and truth
deniers which nobody else
on either side of the aisle is writing
about right now other than me no one
else is writing about that do you want
to solve them that's my question
the proliferation of conspiracy theories
without dealing with fox news it's like
solving terrorism without dealing with
the terrorists well look that's your
opinion i disagree with your opinion
okay so fox news is the promulgator of
conspiracy theories says the anchor on
msnbc which msnbc which spent four long
years claiming that the steele dossier
was probably real
absolutely incredible stuff of course
the goal of saying that fox news is like
a terrorist group is to get fox news
thrown off the air they've been very
clear about all of this
this is the goal
if they can't win then they will attempt
to silence that is what they're going to
do at the school board level it's why
they're attempting to rip your kids away
from you
it is why they are intent on
indoctrinating your children without you
being able to see over their shoulder
the goal is to control the entire
narrative in every aspect of american
life and they will do that either by
top-down stranglehold on institutions or
they will do it by essentially telling
you that it's no business of yours how
they raise your children well the
backlash is coming and it's coming
strong and it should come because this
is the fight of our time and it's the
fight for the next generation all right
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out our newest
podcast morning wire on today's episode
they discuss joe biden meeting with
president xi jinping of china that
episode is available right now on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcast make sure to tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode protesters gather for
the kyle ridden house verdict
whistleblower documents show the fbi is
tracking threats to school boards and
biden meets with china's president
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
bye